I'm sorry the air conditioner is broken I'm
strong in the heat so I'm fine I do
n't wear clothes when I go to sleep If this happens I'll go to the
student council room and study Eh
naked Eh I'll
cut it to the bare minimum
[Music] I
thought it was normal
[Music] It's
normal
Maybe I should have been embarrassed if I
took it off Now that I think about it
as a girl, I'm starting to get embarrassed
Just
don't show me your tattoo It's
okay.
[music]
Miyamura doesn't want to take off his clothes right away in front of people, so I have a body like this, so I can take it
off in front of Toru,
but Ishikawa-kun knows about tattoos.
san, let me ask you clearly
what is it because miyamura isn't that
shy
?
I
should have been embarrassed earlier Okay, let's do it one more time.  I do
n't think I'm unfazed I'm
lying Just a little more than 2 millimeters from my classmate from last time in junior high school
[Applause] I'm really
envious
Miyamura is also spring What is it again?  It wasn't
enough
CD, you idiot, you always take her with you, haha, it
's a lie to say that it's not her, but I'm fine, but I'm
rude to Mr. Hori.
[Music]
I'm
sorry.  I talked about it when I was in junior high school I
got an email
What is that face Ah,
look at the attached image I'm
curious, please stop it
Stop using honorifics
Confused Miyamura It's the first time I've seen you, you're
really stupid